most of Game of Thrones happens in
Westeros home to the Starks and
Lannisters the wall and the Iron Throne
but Daenerys a story starts in the
Eastern continent of Essos with the
Dothraki sea and slavers Bay we also see
Braavos pentose volantis Valyria in the
show and calf but the world of Game of
Thrones is far bigger than we see in the
series the world book describes far
distant cities and kingdoms with their
own cultures histories and mysteries
some of the strangest places are in the
far east of Essos and in the southern
continent of Sethe aureus Sethe aureus
is full of jungle ruined cities and
mystery no one knows how big it is a
dragon rider once spent three years
flying over the continent but she never
found its southern border said it's a
land without end
colonies on South Oreos have all failed
and treasure hunters don't return
because the jungles are full of disease
blood boils sweet rock worm bone red
death archmaester Ebro says the disease
kills half of all Westerosi visitors and
those who survive the sickness are often
killed by the wildlife there are huge
crocodiles carnivorous fish snakes and
basilisks and apes so huge they can kill
elephants with one punch the only animal
that isn't deadly is the purple eyed
lemur called the little valyrian further
south in the Green Hell regions are said
to be vampire bats that can drain a man
of blood and tattooed lizards with claws
on their legs like some kind of
dinosaurs most terrible of all are the
wyverns which are similar to dragons
they don't breathe fire but they're
angry ER to make up for it some kinds
hunt in packs of a hundred or use
stealthy black scales to sneak rid their
prey and if somehow you survive the
wildlife and the disease there are
slavers prowling the coast and there are
the natives Authority called brindled
men they're hairy big boned massively
muscled creatures with noses like snouts
and thick skin like a hog colored white
and brown brindled men can't reproduce
with other humans
the brindled men near the coast have
learned to speak the local trade talk
but the men further south are said to be
savage cannibals who worship Dark Gods
it said that there were once lizard men
and eyeless cave dwellers old races who
were destroyed or devoured by the
brindled man for the greatest mystery of
Sethos is yin yin is a ruined city older
than time and built from massive blocks
of oily black stone no trees or vines
will touch it it's a city so evil that
not even the jungle will enter when
princess Nymeria tried to settle some
Rona in yin the entire population
vanished overnight so that's a Thoris
off its western coast of the basilisk
Isles the festering sore of the summer
sea hot and humid to the Isles swarm
with stinging flies sand fleas and blood
worms old Valyria used a Nile as a penal
colony for their worst criminals in
their city of the gospel eerie and
torturous devised new torments and
practiced blood sorcery mating beasts to
slave women to birth twisted half-human
children it's actually crazy how often
half human children are mentioned in the
books it's possible that ancient
interspecies breeding is what gives the
Targaryen x' their dragon magic and the
Starks their logging powers it's also
possible that some of the twisted
monsters on Sethe oreos might have been
created by a Valyrian blood magic
there's some weird [ __ ] in the books
anyway after the doom Gaga sauce grew
rich and powerful on slavery and sorcery
until it was wiped out in a plague
eventually people returned and the Isles
are now home to pirates in towns with
names like sky [ __ ] gash and black
pudding they have some charming local
customs like piling the skulls of their
enemies on an island as an offering to
some doc God occasionally the Free
Cities come to wipe out the pirates but
the Pirates always come back one time a
captain called Sethos son was sent to
destroy the Pirates and he in
dead became a pirate king who ruled for
30 years and that guy's south or Sun is
an ancestor of Davos as friend
Salladhor saan also in book 5 Barristan
Selmy trains a boy from the basilisk
Isles called Tom Cole oh and Barristan
says he's the best natural swordsman
he's seen since Jamie Lannister which is
high praise one of the basilisk Isles
features an ancient idol of a gigantic
toad of malignant aspect the statue is
40 feet high and carved of greasy black
stone the people of Toad aisle have an
unpleasant fish-like aspect to their
faces and many have webbed hands and
fate
so like yen this is a reference to HP
Lovecraft who wrote about strange fishy
people worshipping strange fishy gods
these black stone structures are
scattered all over the world of Thrones
and it's hinted that they were built by
a Lovecraftian fish people called the
deep ones whose descendants apparently
still live on toad Isle so in conclusion
the world book says the basil is Geils
best avoided a thousands of years ago in
the grasslands of Essos the first
civilizations began legend says that a
silver sea was ruled by Fisher Queens
from a floating palace there were savage
hairy men who rode to battle on unicorns
and a city of labor where acolytes of a
spider goddess ward against those of a
serpent God it said that there was a
kingdom of centaurs who might have just
actually been mounted warriors these are
all just ancient legends but we do know
there was a kingdom called SAR nor thus
are nori called themselves tol men and
they were worried as sorcerers and
scholars they built cities across the
grasslands with canals caravans and
libraries worshipping a hundred gods
Senhora soldiers wore steel and spider
silk and road sized chariots with women
and men fighting together
Sano award against the Karthi and the
Dothraki and even fought in Valyria
sua's against case the Sun Ori were
divided into lots of rival kingdoms
traditionally they were ruled by a high
king in a wonderous palace with a
thousand rooms legend says that the
first High King was called whose or am i
which sounds like azor Ahai the hero who
ended the long night
many of the cultures of Essos have their
own versions of this story it's like how
Noah's Ark and the Epic of Gilgamesh
tell different versions of the same
flood myth
Asano dominated the west grasslands for
thousands of years but after the doom of
Valyria
the Dothraki United an attacked sonoran
force city after city fell and sana was
too slow and divided to fight the threat
they were broken in a final battle
called the field of crows and now their
kingdom lies in ruins fewer than 20,000
told men remain north of Essos is a vast
ocean called the Shivering sea it's full
of fish crabs seals whales and
leviathans the size of Islands sailors
also describe mermaids and drowned
spirits and mists that can instantly
freeze a whole ship there are many
reports of ice dragons colossal beasts
much bigger than regular dragons they're
made of living ice and breathe cold
instead of flame which might explain the
freezing mists when ice dragons die they
melt so no one can prove that they exist
in the far north is an Arctic waste
where the blizzards never end
sailors describe strange lights in the
sky which might be aurora borealis
there are also tales of cannibal bay
where ships enter then a trapped when
the sea freezes behind them it said that
a thousand ships lie entombed in
cannibal bay still inhabited by the
children and grandchildren of their
original crews who survived by feasting
on the flesh of sailors newly caught
much of the Shivering sea is ruled by
the people of the island of AB the urban
EES are short strong and hairy with
ridged brows and massive jaws even E's
can sometimes reproduce with other
humans but the offspring are sterile so
like the brindled men the ebony x' might
be another species of human
kind of like out Neanderthals lived
alongside Homo sapiens in the real world
for a while the Ibanez are cunning
craftsmen hunters and warriors who fish
the Shivering see their whaling ships
are renowned for their strength in
weathering storms and taking whales for
bone blubber and oil the island of it
has dark forests and mountains full of
bears wolves and mammoths many ibanez
live alone in these woods as foresters
or miners but others live in the main
port of eben in the shadow of the god
king's castle a colossal ruin that once
housed a hundred ibanez kings under the
god Kings Eve conquered the forests to
their south which were inhabited by a
small shy forest folk called the if a
cave Ron or the woods walkers the woods
walkers are thought to be related to the
children of the forest of Westeros the
woods walkers carved trees like other
children carve we're woods but the woods
walkers also built a settlement or City
which is cool because we've never seen a
city built by the children in Westeros
the god Kings are gone now and EBEs
ruled by a Council of nobles but the
woods walkers are said to still live in
the deeper woods and will bless a
household that leaves offerings of leaf
and stone east of it we start getting
into the really distant lands author
George Martin warns us that we're seeing
this world from the perspective of
Westerosi maesters whose information on
distant places might not be accurate
distortions and errors creep in here
might be dragons type stuff so
everything from here on in might be
mixed with myth east of AB are the
thousand islands scatter of bleak
windswept rocks they're inhabited by a
strange hairless people with green skin
and teeth filed to sharp points they
said to sacrifice a list of fish headed
gods but they're so afraid of the sea
that they won't touch the water
even on the threat of death some say
that the Thousand Islands are the last
remnants of a drowned Kingdom whose
towns and towers were submerged
thousands of years ago so again this
stuff is
straight out of HP lovecraft south of a
thousand islands is the port city of
Nephi surrounded by cliffs and shrouded
in fog Nephi looks like a small town but
most of the city is hidden underground
so never is called the secret city known
for necromancy and torture east of Nephi
are the grim gray forests of Massa V a
dark land of shape changes and demon
hunters these mysterious lands are as
far east as any Westerosi has been esos
is divided by a great mountain range
called the bones named for the remains
of those who try to cross them the
mountains are riddled with rivers
canyons vast underground caverns and
sunless seas there are passages into the
mountains ancient carved steps and
hidden passages but only a few roads
lead out of the bones the steel road the
stone road and the sand road each of
these are guarded by a fortress city
Kyah Kyah Naya samiri Anna and BIOS Abad
for these cities were once outposts of
the kingdom of her [ __ ] but the lakes
and rivers of her [ __ ] dried up reducing
the kingdom to ruin now only these three
cities remain defended by warrior women
who believe that only those who give
birth a permitted to take life the women
wear iron rings and their nipples and
rubies in their cheeks
trained in combat from childhood most
men in these cities are gelded and live
as eunuchs only the strongest and
handsomest men are allowed to breed and
to rule the cities making the bones a
confusing mix of matriarchy and
patriarchy east of the bones are the
plains of the jogos nigh these guys are
a bit like Dothraki nomadic mounted
warriors roaming across grasslands but
the show goes nyeh don't ride horses
they ride horses which in the real world
hybrids of zebras and horses the sources
of Game of Thrones are similar but tend
to be tough and angry there's a book
character called Vargo hOAT who rides
his horse in Westeros he leads the brave
companions who cut off Jaime Lannister's
and in book three but the jogos nigh are
short and squat with pointed skulls
because they bind their heads when young
which is actually a thing in the real
world groups of Jurgis and I are ruled
by a war chief and a moon singer usually
the Chiefs are men and the moon sing as
women but sometimes they switch roles
and live as the other gender because of
their religion the Joker snide don't
kill other jogos nay but they constantly
wage war on the peoples around them
including the cities of the bones it
said that the jurgis nigh wiped out the
last of the stone giants which were
twice as large as the giants of Westeros
which would make him like 24 feet or 7
meters tall the jugglers may also fight
eet an empire to the south sick of being
raided the et shove tried to wipe out
the Joker's night and one time they got
close under Emperor lo boo but as
ya-gaus' warrior woman called Zia rose
up and destroyed lo boos armies claiming
the Emperor's skull as her drinking cup
ye tea is the oldest and greatest of the
eastern civilizations inspired by
Imperial China a land of hills and
plains jungles and rainforests it's said
to be so wealthy that it's princes live
in houses of solid gold its forests
dense and said to be infested with
basilisks but a web of stone roads
provides safe passage the cities of ute
are more magnificent than anywhere in
Westeros the current Emperor lives in a
palace that's larger than the entire
city of King's Landing so he T is crazy
powerful and legend says that it was
once even greater the great Empire of
the dawn covered most of Far East Essos
with riches and armies even greater than
the Valyrian Empire the first emperor of
Yi T was believed to be a God on earth
son of the Lion of night and the maiden
made of light it said that this first
god Emperor ruled for 10,000 years of
pace until he ascended to the stars et
was then ruled by the Pearl Emperor than
the Jade tourmaline onyx topaz and opal
Emperor's each reign more
troubled than the last finally the
amethyst emperess was killed and aserp
by her brother the bloodstone Emperor he
began a reign of terror
practicing necromancy slavery
cannibalism and torture he took a tiger
woman for his bride and worshipped a
black stone that had fallen from the sky
which might connect to the black stone
of yin and Toad Isle it said that the
bloodstone Emperor caused the long night
when the world went dark and demons
attacked Yi tshh believed that the long
night was ended by the hero azor Ahai so
this seems to be the same story as the
long night in Westeros when the White
Walkers first attacked and were defeated
by the last hero yi t even has a
structure like the wall the huge five
thoughts protect Yi T from the demons of
a freezing desert so are the White
Walkers of Westeros the same as the
demons of ET also the story of the
bloodstone Emperor is really similar to
the Westerosi story of the night's king
they both marry a monstrous woman make
themselves rulers and worship dark
forces they seem to be like different
cultures myths of the same events so
what really happened what caused the
long night and what ended it these
questions are central to the final
season of Game of Thrones and the war to
prevent a second long night from the
White Walkers another mystery is that
the five thoughts are made of fused
black stone difference to the
Lovecraftian oily black stone fused
stone was made by Valyrians with dragon
flame but the five forts predate Valyria
so maybe the great Empire of the dawn
had dragons of their own and another
place with ancient fused stone is the
high tower in Westeros did ancient Yi
teach Dragon Riders build the pyramid
I mean the high tower will go down that
rabbit hole in another video but check
out Lucifer means light bringer on
YouTube who goes real deep on this stuff
the south of Yi T is the island of Leng
it's lush jungles are full of tigers and
apes and it's rich in spice
and gemstones the people of Lange are
some of the tallest in the world many
reaching seven feet tall and they have
better eyesight than other humans for
most of its history Lange was an isle of
mystery closed off to the outside world
the Empress of Lange was known to have
Congress with the old ones gods who
lived in ruined cities deep beneath
Lang's jungles sometimes the old ones
told the Empress to execute all the
strangers on the island that stopped
when ye T invaded Leng and became the
dominant people the ruined cities of the
old ones were sealed off but legends
persist that the old ones still live in
the darkness below so these old ones are
another clear reference to Lovecraft in
fact Leng is the name of a mysterious
interdimensional plateau in a Lovecraft
mythos further to the east there's also
the city of Carcosa ruled by a Yellow
Emperor and Kadath where unspeakable
riots are performed for mad God's author
George Mardan has said that he added
these Lovecraft references basically
just to fill out the map along with
places like the city of the winged men
cities of the Bloodless men and bone
town so these places are just fun world
building probably not that important to
the story but there is one city that
seems central to the world of Ice and
Fire a shy is easternmost and
southernmost the end of the known world
it's a huge city bigger than King's
Landing old town volantis and calf
combined and ash I is built entirely of
Lovecraftian greasy black stone making a
shy dark and gloomy even in the summer
though the city is huge the population
is small there are no crowds or noisy
markets people walk masked and veiled
and alone there are no children in a shy
and no animals apparently they can't
survive the foul pollution of the river
ash the wider area is called the shadow
lands when glowing ghost grass grows and
Dragons stir ash I is a center of dark
magic where red priests blood mages
neckerman
is a nightwalkers practice that terrible
spells apparently magic is stronger in a
shy and seekers come from all over the
world to learn secrets and magic
Melisandre quaithe Marwan and Mary Mazda
all study magic in a shy euron greyjoy
claims to have come and seen wonders and
terrors beyond imagining the masked
shadow binders like Melisandre and
Quaithe are said to be the most sinister
of all the sorcerers of a shy they alone
dare to go up the ash deep into the
shadow lands with as demons and Dragons
and worse in the heart of darkness lies
ste guy the city of the night where even
shadow binders fear to tread so this
place seems like a cosmic center of dark
magic the heart of darkness is like an
opposite pole to the heart of winter in
the north of Westeros but who built a
shy and why build a giant city out of
oily black stone one theory is that the
bloodstone Emperor built it because he
worshipped black stone after all or
maybe a Shia used to be normal stone but
some magical Cataclysm like the long
night transformed it the polluted shadow
lands are like the fallout of some
disaster like the doom of Valyria or
maybe a Shia was built by the
Lovecraftian Deep Ones along with the
cities beneath Lang and yen and the toad
stone all these evil places seemed
interconnected the darkness of a Shai
runs deep
so the world of Game of Thrones is far
bigger than Westeros it's full of exotic
creatures ancient peoples uncomfortable
race undertones Lovecraftian Horrors and
cosmic mysteries and these same forces
of Ice and Fire
are playing out in the final season of
Game of Thrones much of the artwork in
this video is from unseen Westeros an
exhibition of work by 40 Game of Thrones
artists you can see the exhibition for
free in Berlin in January or you can get
a beautiful art book on their
Kickstarter it's got 80 pieces to pick
ding Westeros and beyond many never
before seen this is all non profit this
isn't sponsored just a celebration of
the world of Thrones and the artists who
bring it to life
the Kickstarter is the only way to get
the book and it closes literally like
today so get it while you can
the map in this video is by Clara docks
and other artworks by a drafter g-man
Dee Fink's and Rick's Ian Kevin Catalan
Orianna Weisner Matt Olsen and more
links below
most of the info from this video is from
the world of Ice and Fire which you can
pick up on Amazon to support all Chief
decks at no extra cost to you thanks for
watching please like and subscribe and
thanks to the patrons including Kurtis
Trotter Simon Kern Vijay Ganesh and lve
Cheers
you